all right what's up
y'all riffin with Griffin back again you
know how we
do ladies and
[Music]
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
[Music]
podcast wo wo wo yeah yeah
with
gin with
G what's up y'all welcome back to
Griffin with Griffin your absolute
favorite
podcast um a lot of stuff on the show
today um I saw this documentary the fall
of Minneapolis a different perspective
on the George Floy situation and I want
to give you my
thoughts crazy stuff plus reach season 2
Percy Jackson on Disney
plus um and you know news and notes keep
you updated on what's going on in my
life but anyways thanks again for
[Music]
watching all right anyways thanks for
watching riffin with Griffin I
appreciate you guys being here as always
always live on
Wednesdays um you you know live on
Wednesdays you know how we do it so I
appreciate you guys coming you know uh
and being here putting your comments all
that kind of stuff everything helps
everything helps the podcast move
forward and you know we're trying to do
new stuff for the year um and remember
if you want to be a patreon member or
our our twitch
subscriber um that's stuff is now um
what do you call it you could you know
do that because I have I'm doing ex
extra content on Mondays do like a 15 20
minute episode about like whatever is
happened on the on the weekend or some
special topic that's going on that's
where I'm going to be doing that now and
uh so that's up so make sure you check
that out if that's something you're
interested in if you want to support the
show and uh like I say by the way and
that is where am I at here yeah so
please hit the Subscribe button so you
know when you get these notifications
when I'm going live every
Wednesday and if you know want to watch
me
game you know join the channel but you
should follow the channel anyway because
when I go live on Mondays for the extra
bonus content you can watch it five
minutes of it for if you're not a
subscriber you can watch five minutes of
it for free and then you have to be a
subscriber to like continue so you know
you might want to get a taste so you got
to follow me on Twitch just to to get
that and like I say extra a new extra
patreon content coming every Monday
promise you that you know it's been a
while but I'm actually doing it
now
um so anyways that's where we're at here
on riffin with
Griffon Griffin with Griffon as they
say so anyways welcome guys I see
everybody in chat uh thanks for watching
live on uh you know YouTube and also
thanks for everybody that's all those
truck drivers out there all those people
on the road or all those people that
have like long tedious jobs and you need
something to listen to and you like tune
in to me I appreciate that thank you for
the support and all that stuff so mostly
on Wednesdays now I'm I'm I'm
transitioning into doing more reviews of
things I'm watching and suggestions from
you guys along with giving you little
tidbits about what's going on with me um
I hope my my voice is matched up I have
a new camera system thing set up and I
think it's been messing up but whatever
it's still fine you get it I'll I'll
I'll fix it for next week if if it is a
situation so but anyways like I'm saying
welcome you know um news and notes
what's going on with me as you know uh
you know we're getting close man our due
date is the 27th it's the 27th
so and that's just like right around the
corner man it's so right around the
corner um and if you know hey you want
to you want to you want to send
something to the baby Griffin uh I do
have a Target registry uh chose Target
on purpose because of all the
trolls that are always talking smack
about when that Rachel works at
Target so I said okay cool you know what
I'm going to do we gonna have a Target
registry thank you thank you you know
yeah trolls come on out and so if you
and I and I by the way I I do want to
thank everybody that has sent something
that's a lot of my twitch subscribers
because we've been around my twitch
people we've been around and I'm
actually going to put the link uh in the
description baby Griffin
register yeah you know what I mean I'm G
put that right there so so if you if
you're interested in uh you know you
you're like I want to be a part of that
Griffin I like that so I'm G put that up
in the description anybody that's
interested if you want to uh um do that
you know you don't have to I mean half
of it is like I half of the people that
actually had sent something I actually
know who they are there's a lot of
people that are like on my Instagram who
are my friends who were like yo dude
what's your registry so I put it up
there you know it is what it is you know
what I mean so it is what it is you know
I I always I always thought it was
funny that people were uh you know that
they were they thought that that was
something that was going to bother me
like it's like Rachel wanted to work you
know she wanted to be a visual
merchandiser and she got the job she has
actually hasn't been her pregnancy has
been tough so she hasn't even been back
to work I don't even know if she will I
told her she didn't have to you know
what it is it's like my mom you know my
mom I remember well you know as you know
guys my mom has dementia um it's tough
it's tough for me because one of the
things my mom always said to me is like
you got to have a kid when you have a
kid when you have children you'll know
you'll understand you know and it's just
I just really wanted her to see this she
always wanted me to get married and have
kids you know and it just sucks
that it happened at a time when I don't
know she's all there you know what I'm
saying it's tough you know but I do
remember one of the things my mom said
to me when I was younger she you know uh
she'd be like man I cuz she was a single
mom you know my mom was a single mom
only child and I was only child but her
thing was like she wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom I remember her saying
that to me she was like I wish I could
have stayed at home
you know she wanted that so I always
said when I get
married my mind I have kids I want that
option to be there for my wife if you
don't want to go to work you don't have
to if you think this is important to
stay home and take care of the kid and
so I
given Rachel that option I was like hey
you don't got to do you you don't have
to you you achieved what you wanted you
know you wanted to be a visual
merchandiser and you got it but if you
just want to stay here and raise our
kids help you know be there all the time
cuz that's what you find important cuz
that's what my mom wanted to do you you
I want you to do that so who
knows but
anyways uh you know what I mean it's
like it yeah I know that uh Jose mom had
to exactly I don't I don't begrudge my
mom at all she had to she had did my mom
gave me a great life like my mom taught
me a lot of you know about hard work
about like you know she she made time
for me she did you know I always had a
good birthday party I always had like
you know she would take you know I
remember I always remember my birthdays
like we would go to like she I could get
like three or four of my friends and she
would take us to Magic Mountain you know
and then she would be like all right you
guys go and then she would do whatever
and come back and pick us up you know I
always remember those kind of things so
she made time you know what I
mean um so you know it's just it's just
like you know life gets in the way you
know what I'm saying y'all life gets in
the way uh I appreciate that mic but uh
you know it's probably better to go over
to you to to to um either patreon or the
twitch but thank you for the member you
can also be a YouTube member guys and
you just reminded me I got to put these
videos up on YouTube um but anyways so
you know it is what it is I don't know
why I'm going on a tangent but we are
here we're getting close man due dates
to 27th and we're just like it's like I
just want it to happen already you know
what I mean like just get here so we can
just to start that part of our life so
I'm a little anxious about this like
child birth and like I want Rachel to be
okay and am I going to handle this what
do I want to see it you know what I mean
like it's like so overwhelming but like
you know it's all it's it's probably
adorable for all you parents out there
who are like oh look at this firsttime
parent you know I just feel like I guess
I'm
um mature enough now to like you know
maybe I intellectualize things too much
that's the part of being a comic and a
and a podcaster is like just overthink
everything because that's great for
podcasting and doing comedy but when
it's time to live real life it's just
like you know so we'll
see but anyways um yeah I see a lot of
comments in there about when your kids
are when your wives were started working
again and you know I get it you know
here's Heather 22 said the kid wants the
mom home you know you know I I I believe
that you know but you know we live in a
it's like we have weird agenda in
society about what they you know there
was like this feminist movement makes it
seem like if you're a woman and you want
to stay at home and raise your kids
somehow that's wrong somehow that's bad
somehow you're not being a strong
independent woman and it's just like
what how about instead of being a strong
independent woman or or or some Macho
chauvinistic guy how about like let's
have a good family unit and whatever
that is in that family unit that you're
supporting each other if one person is
you know able to support the where they
can be have the best environment for
their kid maybe that should be what the
discussion is about but you know how it
is with agendas man people got agendas
and it's just like it's craziness out
there we live in crazy times man that's
what I say we live in crazy times but
anyways thanks for being here uh got a
big discussions today on the show but in
the meantime let's go let's go to
comments and see what people have had to
say this past week uh on the
comments um you know Carl W 2798 he said
riffin with Griffin let's
go I appreciate that um and then
somebody said novice 127 asked where can
I find Kyle quismundo music especially
this intro song it's impossible to find
okay one he didn't make oh oh Kyle you
know what oh I see you're commenting on
a different episode yeah he's on um he's
on Instagram you know he is on Instagram
uh if you just look up his name on
Instagram uh I haven't talked to him in
a while actually I got to I got to hit
him up you reminded me to hit him up uh
cool dude great producer man the guys
that have sent me music on the show some
great dudes man they they sent some
really hot stuff so check that
out
um let's see here all right uh downs and
Drome that's what this guy's name is
Downs I n d r o a m keep posting these
Eric you're showing up on my feet
constantly and my wife too maybe the
algo gods are shining upon you I hope so
I hope
so so that's pretty good
uh I don't know let's see let's see the
what's one from last
week let's see oh somebody said Ricky J
star stir 2586 said as old cliche goes
Jimmy Kimmel does protest too much
there's a reason eh I don't know about
that I mean you know it's just like all
those all that Epstein stuff that came
out like you know it's it's crazy how
guilt you everyone's Guilty By
Association so you know it's like this
isn't some official inquiry they had
this some like this is the official list
no this is just Discovery in a lawsuit
and people's names came up with no
context in a lot of those people like no
like so they just said anybody that
Jeffrey Epstein was associated with ever
is somehow Guilty By Association so
that's a little unfair but
whatever
um bring me creatures said I'd love to
hear some random music reviews just like
the movie ones but about one of your
favorite albums you know
what that's actually really great idea
you know that's actually a really great
idea but you know the only thing for me
right now is music feels like Family Guy
episodes you you know and what do I mean
by that it's like you know I don't know
if you ever you guys ever watch Family
Guy but they have those like cutaways
you know what I
mean um those cutaways and so like I
remember cutaways more than I remember
say what the episode was about I think
albums are like that now that it's all
about singles you know you know when my
day I don't want to be sound like the
old guy but in my day um you know people
put out an album and sometimes the album
would have a story and there would be a
couple of songs on there that wouldn't
make the radio but they'd be some of
your favorite songs and so you had like
this like you know what was this album
about it would it' just be like a great
album and you're like oh I love that
album like I don't think people really
talk about that anymore you know and so
now it's all about singles so now these
like BigTime artists that have a lot of
money they'll like reach out to like you
know 25 producers and be like hey guys
can you make me songs and then they have
like a sort of Lottery system that'll be
like all right so I'm going to pick 15
of my favorite singles from all these
producers and then they put that on like
that's their album now that's streamed
on Spotify or whatever the music
platform and then it just becomes about
hit singles you know I don't necessarily
like
that but there's still people out there
trying to be you know an artist and I
think people become misunderstood like
that it's like I don't know if you guys
saw that thing most deaf he doesn't call
himself that anymore he was talking
about Drake's music like it's not really
hip-hop well to me that's someone that
only listens to the what comes out as
the popular Billboard top 100 like all
those Drake songs that come out um that
like the the sort of like pop crossover
hit songs they're fine but man you got
to listen to some of you go into Drake's
album I love those songs
you know what I'mma I'm just G to do
this right now let me just uh let me
just pull this up like I love the songs
like there' be like some like bside
tracks you know they don't even call it
that anymore but there'll be like some
bid tracks that I really like that I
think this shows uh you know who Drake
is like for instance on the certified
Lover Boy song certified Lover Boy album
my favorite song on that album album is
called the remorse it's the last track
on the album track number 21 check that
out that to me is when Drake's at his
best so but like you know that's not the
stuff that's gonna make the radio you
know and how many times do you like
listen
to how many times you gonna listen to
like the whole album anymore because you
know the attention span is so low so
people are just kind of like oh I'm just
going to listen to the couple songs I
heard or you listen to so many like a
certain playlist and it doesn't have you
know what I mean and nowadays you could
just be like hey you know you you talk
to Siri or you talk to um uh you know
Alexa or whatever you use and you just
could be like hey play this and you can
like cultivate and make a a playlist
that's specifically to what you like as
opposed to like hearing this artist out
and
see what what you like about this like
art that they put out so but
anyway um yeah some people it's not for
everybody like this guy txxt in the chat
said Drake is the worst rather listen to
Nails on a chalkboard that's a little
harsh man you know what I mean that's a
little
harsh so whatever I'm like you know what
I'm not GNA get into this because you
guys are getting crazy on me all right
so now let's get a little bit serious
here uh serious discussion coming
prepare yourselves for that this is the
review section
of the podcast so I was on Golden hour
and uh Chris brought up this thing he
saw this documentary he saw and it's
called the fall of
Minneapolis it's called the fall of
Minneapolis and they have a
website um wait what's going on here oh
that's not oh man my thing's not
working well that freaking sucks sorry
so now I can't even uh I can't even go
to the uh the thing right now just
messed up I don't know what happened
there but whatever if you're listening
it doesn't matter we'll just anyways so
I have to I can't go to like my you know
stuff on the screen because it's
glitched but anyways I just talk about
it so to fall of Minneapolis it's um
it's a documentary and it's like you
know how they describe it
is uh based on conversations with those
who were there including Derek shavin
Thomas Lane and other Minneapolis police
officers who've never spoken out before
Li Liz exposes how the facts were
manipulated to dupe and divide America
so this is about the George Floyd arrest
uh and Death of George Floyd you know
and so I just and then like it's a very
great website if you go to the fall of
minap fallof minneapolis.com you know
and I actually should put this in the
description and I will um you know this
is like a very uh interesting
I'm yeah I'm put that in the
descriptions if anybody wants to go to
the the website because you know you
they really they have an agenda they
really do first of all I'm I'm always
Leary of any documentary like documentar
is all about pushing their own agenda
they're you know and they use the facts
in a way to to push forward their agenda
and you know but that doesn't mean that
the facts that they have here aren't
valid or important to see so that is one
thing I want to say and this is a very
intense website and you know they show
the research that they did that you can
see all of their references where they
got the information from and uh you know
it's very
interesting thing so first of all this
documentary is like now they want to
expose that there was more to what
happened with George Floyd than the than
the press and the media and politicians
and everything put out and you know when
you watch this
the crazy part is like so this thing
opens up and immediately they're showing
you the body cam the the cops body cam
footage and they just open with that you
know they they they open the B they open
up and they show you like what the cops
perspective about what happened when
they first arrived on the scene so they
arrive on the scene and the the the the
store the store owner was like yeah I'm
get I got some fake bills from and
that's the guy over there and it's
George Floyd in his car you know so the
cops come over to the car and he's in
the driver's seat and you know he's not
being very Cooperative at all and so you
know and you have to like to me this
body cam footage should have came out
immediately you know because because of
what was happening in the country like
you watch this body cam footage and it
tells a completely different story than
the narrative that was put out there
because if you're not from Minneapolis
and you're just sitting at home and you
hear about this you know what are we
supposed to trust you we you know the
news comes on whatever you watch whether
it be fox or CNN whether it be like
MSNBC or you're on one of those other
conservative whatever it is the news
comes out and we don't know if you think
about it what do we know we're just
watching TV and we hear black man killed
by cops in
Minneapolis things that already been
going on in the country for you know
that
year so everybody freaks out and it
turns into a thing but I you know cooler
heads didn't Prevail but I'm going get
into why I think that kind of stuff
happens what I'm just trying to get into
right now is like watching this
documentary and what it means now I
think you should watch it with a grain
of salt I think you should also watch it
and think also that there is a bigger
picture here that doesn't mean it
doesn't absolve the cops to me it
doesn't absolve the neighborhoods and
and the people's reaction no no but it
is a discussion that should be had but I
tell you you look at this body cam
footage and it tells a completely
different story first of all he
definitely looked like he was high on
something he he was not Cooperative with
the police at all you know and and these
are the first cops that came on the
scene right and then there's like the
people in the car with him are like dude
stop like just do what the guy says
there's a stranger on the street who's
like hey man just you you stop resisting
you know it's like this is from the body
cam footage
right if you just
believe especially liberal
media they portrayed a thing where the
cops came got them didn't care about him
threw him on the ground the dude put his
had his knee on his neck and killed him
that's the message that they put out you
look at his body cam footage and it's
like that's not what happened
man he was very uncooperative and not
only that just from looking at the body
cam footage I'm no I'm no forensics
expert or nothing like that this dude
look like he was high as hell he looked
like something was wrong with him you
know what I'm saying it looked like
something was wrong with him it looked
like you know and he was not paying
attent you know he was like don't shoot
me don't shoot me and the cops like I'm
not going to shoot you like get do what
I say he wouldn't do it he wouldn't get
into the back of the car he was like I'm
claustrophobic I'm claustrophobic you
know he just was like he was like he was
didn't seem like he was all there and
what's crazy even in the video the the
initial cops on the scene they were like
he caught a
paramedics like we never heard that
before but right on the body cam video
the cop is saying called the paramedics
cuz in his mind he was like oh
something's up with this dude okay all
right so now this documentary is trying
to portray that yeah man he died from
drugs right that he died from what was
going on with him see I disagree with
that part of it and I'll tell you why in
a
second but what I'm saying is this the
facts and the case of of everything that
happened in this documentary is like
very fascinating and I do suggest you
you watch it you I think that this is
the kind of information that everyone
should be like oh I got to see this I
can't just believe everything that I see
even with this documentary I would say
but don't believe everything you see in
terms of like uh the narrative that
they're trying to push
[Music]
um you know what I mean and I agree I
see people in the chat talking about it
like get your news from both sides I
mean I totally agree I'm all about that
you know there's people that think I'm
some kind of liberal whatever it's like
y'all don't you don't know me then you
know I just want the truth I just want
the facts I just want discussion and I
think that that's what was missing in
this situation you know but what I'm
saying is this okay so here's the point
I'm trying to make I believe that this
documentary is trying to show that this
dude was high and he died because he had
hypertension and all that my point
though is like
see they were showing also in this
documentary that he was arrested before
and was doing the same thing he he he
put drugs in his mouth because he was
trying to swallow them because the cops
were there the cops like spit that out
spit that out you know but they handled
that situation completely differently
the F this other time he was arrested
because and my question is and if there
are cops out there if there are cops
that listen to my podcast or you know a
cop or you know anything about this get
into the comments from me please because
my thing is is there a procedure if a
cop comes on the scene and the person
the perpetrator is high uh older or
something's wrong with them and it's
visibly something's wrong with him is
there a different procedure in how you
would get this guy on the ground arrest
him is there something to that is there
some kind of thing where they go because
it seems to me that in the first arrest
of not the first but the the the
previous times he'd been arrested in the
documentary the cops handled it
differently like they called the again
the paramedics had to come they're
checking his blood pressure they're
making sure you know what I mean so
here's what I think happened like I say
it's very nuanced okay so that these
initial cops come they're dealing with
him for like a long time you know and
then the new guy then sioban whatever
his name is that cop and the other Cops
show up I don't know if there was a
discussion between the cops of like yo
yeah we've been dealing with this guy
for a while we called the paramedics
something's up with him cuz these guys
came and then they were doing like
according to this documentary a a by the
book trained technique of how you keep a
suspect in custody who is not being
cooperative okay so to me I think that
and then then that cop got him down put
his knee on his neck which is apparently
what they're trained to do
uh and that wasn't allowed in the trial
by the way that's what's like
mindblowing is like a lot of this
stuff you know wasn't allowed in this
trial but I think that the the my point
of contention here is
that if some like putting your knee on a
dude's neck who has hypertension and is
on drugs contributed to the guy's death
whether it's murdered or not is I'm not
going to question I'm not going to talk
about that what I'm saying is just
because this guy was on fentol whatever
it is like that and then you know that
doesn't mean that doesn't absolve the
cops of partial blame for his murder for
his death I'm saying you know what I
mean so that's why I'm saying I think
that all this evidence that they're
trying to show to try to be like oh look
what happened I don't know if it
absolves those particular cops cuz I
think there was something something went
wrong here you know what I mean
something the communication the flow on
the scene didn't seem to go from the
initial cops who were there to the to to
the two cops that showed up and
eventually ended up being a part of his
death so that's what I'm saying there's
Nuance there but the other part of this
documentary that I thought was
fascinating is all of these police
officers in Minneapolis are are are are
talking out they're being like what
what's going on they they didn't
appreciate how they handled the riots
how they let a Precinct just get taken
over and you know they're coming across
like the mayor of Minneapolis was like
using this as some sort of
political grandstanding and like you
know it's like and I feel like a lot of
that is true you know I feel like this
kind of stuff is weaponized by the media
for agendas and I think that that's
wrong you know I really do I think that
like and and how is that allowed to
happen well if you have a city or
there's a feeling going on in the
country of that the cops are doing
something wrong or there's some kind of
Disconnect between the police and the
neighborhoods and that's been going on
for years and years and years and then
there's little news stories pop up about
the cops did this the cops did that then
when something like this happens it it
could be weaponized and that's what I
think happened this George Floyd
situation was weaponized and it did
divide us and I think that that's
wrong you know it's wrong like this
information we should have taken a
beat we should and now and now moving
forward for me I'm not believing
anything I just see on the news from any
side right or left until I get all the
facts my thing is like can I see more
information before I just believe what
you're saying because like just the body
cam footage
alone tells a different story like when
I saw this body cam footage I was like
oh man what happened here now I'm not
saying that like I'm not like look
George Floyd was did he he was in the
wrong in terms of the dude was you know
giving fake money I don't know I don't
even know what happened with that didn't
they didn't really I don't remember them
talking about that you know but the
police were called on this guy and he
clearly and he had a criminal record you
know they ran and like hey hey check uh
what's your name all right and they gave
his name so they were they checking on
him they know something's up here you
know they know something's up um and
just
like you look at it and you go yeah that
dude was high you know what I'm saying
like maybe he was or wasn't but he was
acting up he was resisting arrest he was
making it very difficult for these
police and he put them in a very bad
situation and it contributed to his
death like straight up okay
so you know what I mean it's so it's
like I think that like this is just one
source of information I and I'm I'm
giving it like I think you should watch
this I think you should watch this
documentary the fault of
Minneapolis uh take it with a grain of
salt because you know obviously
this person that made this documentary
was very Pro police they were very much
like f felt like this was unfair
portrayal of what happened and they're
right it was an unfair portrayal but
that doesn't mean that like that that it
it isn't more nuanced than than what
they what's put out there it's not black
and white it's not the cops are bad and
the people are being wronged no I think
that like this issue it goes back to
like what's going on in the communities
you know like the police officers don't
live in the communities so they look at
these people as like ah they're the
enemy it's like I'm in Enemy Lines I
feel like the issue is that the cops
don't Patrol the neighborhoods and get
to know people you know what I mean and
then on the other side people don't
respect the cops they don't respect
authority they don't respect like the
what's you know they think they can just
get away with whatever and I'm not
talking about everybody I'm saying like
the the criminal element like there's no
feeling of like these cops are here to
protect us and we should respect them
and that's wrong too on both sides you
know so it's like what I'm saying is
that contributes to when something like
this happens then it just blows up and
then like these idiot politicians try to
take advantage you know that's where the
[__] is weaponized man it's not it's not
good you know and then what happens too
is we live in a world of Silence right
now so like there's no discussion like
you should be able to talk about this I
should be able to look at this
documentary and then have a discussion
with people like yo so what do we think
about what happened here and then is
there some Nuance in this is there like
you know where's the blame go it's not
one it's not ultimately one person's
fault or the other person's fault can we
discuss this situation no because here's
what happens and this comes a lot from
the left if I now am looking at this and
being like yo I think there's more to
this what ends up happening is the left
people go Oh no you're a right-wing nut
now you're a right-wing nut uh you know
you don't believe you it's like so you
go oh so you don't want to talk so you
don't want to like talk about what
happened and how this affected the world
how this affected the United stat I mean
of the world actually because they were
they were talking about this in Europe
there were that actor from Star Wars was
out in England like you know no justice
no peace and all so this was like a
worldwide phenomenon that happened but
like there was more to
this so what ends up happening is you
start talking about this and the sort of
left people they criticize you they make
you feel like and then you know what you
do you end up being like oo I'm not g to
say anything then you just live in
silence and you just let things
happen you know and then on the other
side the other side they only see black
and white like it's crazy both sides are
doing the same thing in terms of like
one side the left they some make
everything about race and gender and you
know and then the other side they do it
in the opposite the reverse but do the
same thing you know it's like if I'm
talking to a right if I'm talking to
this person right now and I'm bringing
up the point of like well like because
this is my real point about this uh fall
of Minneapolis and and and how it and
how it happened it's like everybody's to
blame in this in my opinion that's why I
need to know is there some sort of
procedure is there some sort of like
trained procedure when you get on the
scene and the person's High the person
is not in their right mind do you treat
them the same as someone do you is do
you treat them exactly the
same I don't to me I don't think you
should you know if someone's older or
two if something's like are you going to
treat them exactly as every criminal TR
treated the same is every situation
treated the same because what I'm saying
is this he was clearly high on something
in in in my opinion looking at this body
cam footage he was not of his right mind
whatever reason that is if it would
could have been drugs or it just could
have been he wasn't in his right
mind them roughhousing him contributed
to his death now whether they are
completely to blame are they murderers
I'm not going to talk I don't I don't
know okay but I'm telling you that it
should be discussed in that way you know
it should be discussed in that way cuz
they're putting this documentary out to
show oh by the way here's something else
in the documentary that was wild and I
don't know if it's true or not but let's
say what they're saying is
true um the official autopsy the
official
autopsy shows a different picture too
the official autopsy was he had fentanyl
in his system the official
autopsy show that he had there were
issues he had health conditions you know
right and then the family they're saying
in this documentary I don't know if it's
true or not that they hired independent
people who according to the documentary
didn't even get to examine the body like
they didn't even examine the body they
didn't and then they're the ones that
are out there in the Press like this one
black woman and this one older white guy
are out there saying yeah
he died because of the
cops
so you look back at this now and you're
like whoa and then of course it sparked
what it sparked throughout the whole
nation and I just think that that
was it's shameful if
um if this was you know if this was
crazy you know someone in the chest that
imagine if he was armed well here's the
thing though the initial cops on the
scene you know they guy had the gun on
him the guy was like show me your hands
so like George Floyd like you watch the
body cam footage just like even if you
just watch the body cam footage you'll
be like oh yeah this is
different this is different than what
was portrayed because George Floyd
wouldn't put his other hand up so the
guy's like show me your hands show me
he's yelling at him show me your hands
and J Flo's like no please don't shoot
me don't shoot me and the guy's just
kind of like well put you damn hands on
the steering wheel man so he eventually
finally puts his hands on the steering
wheel right but like you know the cops
like what the hell so like they got him
out of the car they searched him they
found a weed pipe on him they F you know
what I'm saying that's another thing too
they found something on them right you
know they this is a lot happened before
he was on the ground they tried to get
him in the car for like 10 15 minutes he
wouldn't good in the car he was like I'm
claustrophobic I'm claustrophobic and he
was like being very un uh uh uh uh what
do you call it he just wasn't being
helpful with the the the with the
cops then the freaking the the the two
cops that were charged with his murder
show up so a lot of stuff happened
before they even got
there and I think there was some kind of
miscommunication to me it looked to me
like those cops should have like got
with each other but you going up on the
scene and you seeing your fellow cops
dealing with something and this this guy
is like acting up they don't know and
that's why I think that's why the cops
are culpable for what happened to them
is what I'm saying but again it's
nuanced but
anyways you know you gotta uh you just
what I'm saying is the whole point of
why I'm bringing this up is just to say
look at it just watch it get a different
perspective you can still look at this
and still believe yeah those cops are
wrong right but all I'm saying is is I
wish we would have had all of this
information you know out in the Press
like where was the news man like the
news should have been like okay we have
the body cam footage uh this is what
happened they didn't do that man they
just fan the flame of this and that
mayor of Minneapolis man that dude I
don't know what his agenda was like the
whole thing seem suspect to me the whole
thing should have been handled
completely differently but again how was
something like this allowed to happen it
was allowed to happen because of how
look at look at what's going on in the
chat people don't want to discuss things
they don't want to talk about Nuance
they don't want to talk they want to
make it everything about it's right and
left and if you're not right you're left
if you're not left you're right but you
know what there's some sensible
[__] out there who want to live
in the middle because we want to find
out what's going on here and I think
that this is an example of
go find out like from moving forward
guys take your take take a beat we
should all take a beat now because now
we know what kind of world we're living
in right now that it's too political
it's too divided and information is
power and they're using it to weaponize
the masses of people who don't care
about the facts who cares about the
facts now people don't care about the
facts people just care about their Echo
chamber you know they just well this is
how I feel and
boom you know what I'm saying
so it's uh yeah man you know like I say
I'm not taking a an opinion either way
in terms of like I think that what I
what what I've learned from this is like
oh there was more to this than what they
let us know and people don't care
anymore now so y'all moved on people
have moved on you know they just move on
that's how we are as a society we just
move on and so but there's lives that
have been affected so now it's like you
go back and you got to look at it and
maybe there's going to be they're going
to be like
oh uh this is what happen and maybe it
should change things you know maybe
there should be a different procedure
for when you get on the scene and a
person is clearly but the one cop this
is something they don't talk about in
the body cam footage the cops like
caught a paramedic like if like like it
happened right away when they were
dealing with him they saw something's up
with this guy caught a
paramedics
so it's
like whoa you know what I mean like they
they portrayed this completely
differently I don't know about you but
like you're at home you're seeing the
riots and everything and they're talking
about what happened and like you know
they definitely made it seem like they
pulled the guy out of the
car and they whatever talked to him
threw him down on the ground and put
their and the guy put his knee in his
neck and killed him like that is how
it's being portrayed and just look at
the body cam footage that's not what
happened
so
uh yeah so somebody said uh the new info
was from the 20page autopsy report that
was publicly released by The County
Medical examiner's office June 30th 2020
has not been changed since like yeah
that's what I'm saying like there's also
when you go to this website that I have
a link in the profile they show all of
their sources where they got this stuff
from and so you could read if you wanted
to you could do your own research and
look into all this stuff I'm just saying
like this is like there there's more to
it than that all right guys let's get to
a lighter note here okay so wow I wanted
to talk about that you know I wanted to
review and have a discussion about it
and I just again I think that I think
that like guys don't don't shy away from
discussion it doesn't have to be
ultimately like one side versus the
other I think it's important to decipher
the facts and information and and make
an informed choice and if you don't know
anything about this I'm pretty sure none
of y'all can make an informed choice
just based off what CNN says right and
in the same way these people who are
clearly you know but again when you hear
all what the all the police offic they
interviewed in this I'm just o it just
gave me a different perspective and a
bad taste in my mouth all right I wish
my thing was working it's not I don't
know why it's not working oh but one
thing that's cool is that at least oh I
can't let's talk about this one first
because it's like at least this is
showing up you know I don't know why
it's doing this man I don't know why
it's doing this but I I want to talk
about Reacher season two Reacher season
2 is let me see if I can fix it maybe I
can fix it screen cap
I don't know why it's doing this um I
yeah I really don't know why it's doing
this but it is what it is maybe if I
change it will it change no it doesn't
change you know I don't know why it's
doing that anyways whatever so Reacher
season 2 uh I I liked Reacher season one
I don't know if you guys it's you know
the Tom Cruz movie that's what made it
famous but this guy that plays
[Music]
um what's his name Alan richson he
actually is a more example of what
Reacher was supposed to be in the uh
Original Series in in the book I'm
saying so the season one I really
enjoyed season one I thought it was um
yeah you know what I mean I thought it
was it was it was an interesting story
and I like that it went like Eight
Episodes 10 episodes so they told the
complete story you got to know all the
characters and it was great season 2 is
a little far-fetched to me I do still
like it but it's very much like you know
kind of cliche stuff there's a bad guy
that's getting weapons and they and
they're going to do a terrorist attack
and Reacher and his team have to stop it
and then you know there's like a Twist
and you know it's like
so it went from like a really
interesting show to sort of like now
it's like a guilty pleasure which isn't
bad it's not bad so um
you
know it's like so they say that the
former military police Jack Reacher
solves crimes and meets out his own
brand of Street Justice I mean that's
like sounds like a you know a show it's
like The A Team or something like that
right so you know it's just it's it's
like it's weird it's it's it turned into
that like the SE the second season
turned into that man so but it again
it's good though you know what I mean I
just sometimes I like sometimes you know
you want something to be like completely
different not artsy fartsy but you want
like what you know how's this different
from other shows like you've seen this
show before season 2 is like a show
you've all you've seen before like you
know this is like
some you know some Revenge movie or some
like you know some thing like that that
you've seen a million times that's what
this is now you know it's turned it's
turned into that
so it's like but again it's not it's not
somebody said a straight edge Death Wish
totally great that's that great example
like a PG-13 Death Wish that's what it
is too yeah you know because you're just
kind of like you know what you know what
my problem with like shows like this are
is like my thing is like just keep it
rated R like if it's going to be adult
make it adult it's like when you saw
when they made Logan remember Logan the
movie Logan so it's like the last
Wolverine movie but it was the first
time they made it rated R and it was
like the first time you saw those
claws actually cut people like actually
cut arms off actually go into people's
head and you see the blood the first
time I saw that I was like oh [__] this
oh you're right it's like but then in
your mind you go well of course the
claws would do that they're freaking
razor sharp claws yeah they're going to
cut you know but what I like that though
I like like if it's going to be adult
make it adult don't make it PG-13 and
then like sort of like you which you
still doing adult
Concepts Reacher ain't for kids right so
then don't act like it's for kids just
let me see some heads blowing up and
like you know blood guts and Gore and
then tell an adult story so I'm on that
I prefer that you know but that being
said it's still a great series I do
recommend it it's a fun watch how about
that it really is a fun watch but I did
enjoy season one more than I enjoyed
season
two um so there's
that um all right so the other show that
I wanted to just give you a brief thing
about is I'm also watching Percy Jackson
and the Olympians on the Disney
Channel I like it you know I like this
I'm a I'm a fan if you know me I'm a fan
I love fantasy books man when I do my
book club I talk about my fantasy books
I love I'm reading I'm reading a couple
of fantasy Ser well I listen to audio
books so I'm listening to a couple
audiobook Series right now but I love
this like so I remember the movies they
did Percy Jackson and and the Olympians
I remember the movies and it was you
know it was fine you know what I mean it
kind of got hokey towards the end but
now they're doing a series again and
they rebooted it and as Disney does you
know how Disney they reboot stuff and
then and then and then they woke ay it
right that's the prevailing thought
that's out there about Disney right but
I'll say this with this thing first of
all when it's to make believe stuff I
don't
care so in this movie it's like Percy
Jackson is a white boy right his name's
Percy Jackson but you know he could have
been black for all I know they could
have just named him Percy you know you
know what I mean they could have done
that if they wanted to and it's fine who
cares you know uh the other girl the
Athena's daughter she's black and then
uh the the Seder guy from the story they
made him like I don't know what he is
but he's brown okay so my first thought
is like when you see this you go uhoh
are they doing this again and it sucks
that you feel that way don't it suck I
mean I think it sucks that your first
thought when you watch something Disney
is like all right what did they change
or what you know but give this a chance
because in this thing once you get past
that initial thought and you look at
these people it really doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it you know and I think
it's well done I think it's well done I
think it's well acted I think the adults
that show up in the story are doing a
great job and that's all I care about is
I just wanted to be believable you know
I want the story to be believable I want
I think that the three kids they they
could be doing a better job if I'm being
if I'm being honest you know I think
that this is like but they're they've
got their groove as the series has went
on so I watch it every week and I think
it's pretty good and like I say I think
the adults that show up are pretty good
and you know Andy e says Percy Jackson a
black dude no but it sound like he could
be a black dude right no Percy Jackson's
white he's a white
kid you know I mean but it's like I
always thought that even in the past
when when I read I was like oh Percy
Jackson okay okay we going to get like a
you know but it's like no he's a white
kid
[Laughter]
uh um no I'm not going to talk about the
aliens um that's a I I got to look into
it first you know what I mean it's like
it's like that uh police presence you
know in Miami biggest police presence
ever they said it's like what's that
about right but we'll talk about it
another
time so check out I do like I said if
you like if you're into fantasy you know
or you have kids and you want to watch
something kind of light you know but I I
mean again I love this kind of stuff
like if a vampire story comes out I
watch it because I love vampires you
know and I love fantasy science sci-fi
stuff so I'm watching Percy Jackson I
think they're doing a good job I think
it's a you know I get I so I give this I
give this and I give Reacher to like you
know both of them get like six woo Woos
woo woo
[Music]
wo yeah so uh both
watchable but anyways guys uh that's
we're coming to an end here uh I
appreciate you uh you know make sure you
uh subscribe you know what I mean you
got to subscribe so you can get um the
notifications when when I'm going live
because when I go live you gotta you
know you gotta show up baby you gotta
show up
bab and and then make sure you twitch
follow follow me on Twitch
and the reason why you should follow me
on Twitch is like I go I'm going to go
live on Twitch every Monday is as is
bonus content for the you know riffin
with Griffin you know I really get I
call it Monday Nuance you know so I
might go into something that I saw and
we just we have like a you know a raw
discussion about it because that's what
I think is important and that's what I
like to do so make sure you guys um do
that and of course like I say if you
want to be a patreon member now and I
know I've been saying this for years
like oh patreon I'm G to do stuff but
guys I actually
[Music]
am I actually am doing stuff on there so
make sure you guys check that out now
somebody brought up KY quismundo earlier
in the chat or on that on that thing so
let me go for because you know what time
it
is ladies and gentlemen yeah rap recap
welcome to welcome to
[Music]
with
Griffin we ain't sniffing you know how
we
living
likey these raps I'm
giving check out first Jackson that [__]
is good check out rich I wish you would
get your facts about that [__] check out
that documentary you wish you
[Music]
in
your get your
facts don't
[Music]
[Laughter]
Bex anyways
guys thanks for watching thanks for
being a part of the discussion let's get
into the comments and you know see what
Happ happens uh and I'll see you guys
next week peace